هنا في انقره احتشدت المعارضه بعدتها
وعديدها لاطلاق برنامج عملها لمرحله ما
بعد اردوغان في حال وثق الناخبون بها
واوصلها الى السلطان
ما يعرف بالطاوله السداسيه وهي تجمع لسته
احزاب معارضه اطلقوا وثيقه السياسات
المشتركه وتتضمن خطبه عمل الوزاره
والمؤسسات الحكوميه اذا حازت صناديق
الاقتراعي الى جانب المعارضه
النظام البرلماني هو كلمه السر لحل ازمات
تركيا كما يقول معارضوا الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان الذي حاز صلاحيات واسعه في النظام
الرئاسي بناء عليه فان للرئيس الولايه
الدستوريه واحده من سبع سنوات
بصلاحيات محدوده
ضمن عمليه الاصلاح
من خلال ادخال قانون ينص على انتخاب
الرئيس لولايه واحده فقط مدتها سبع سنوات
اصلاح الاقتصاد ومكافحه التضخم هو العنوان
الثاني في خطه المعارضه كسب ودي وقلوب
الناخبين هو ما تريده الاحزاب السته عبر
وعود كثيره لتحسين دخل الفرد السنوي وخفض
معدلات البطاله وتوفير فرص عمل جديده
افلاسيونال
الى خانه واحده خلال عامين وننهي غلاء
المعيشه مع جهودنا في مكافحه التضخم سنزيد
معدل النمو باكثر من 5%
وثيقه المعارضه تضمنت وعودا باحترام حقوق
الانسان والحريات العامه ودعم قضايا
المراه لكن هذا كله مرتبط وفق ما يراه
كثير بالاتفاق اولا على مرشح مشترك
لمنافسه اردوغان ونبذ الخلافات التي اخر
ظهور المرشح
تحاول المعارضه الاستفاده من الوضع
الاقتصادي المتردي في برنامجها الانتخابي
لذا ركزت على اصلاحها كاهم اولوياتها
وارفق ذلك باصلاح النظام السياسي والعوده
الى النظام البرلماني وتقييد مده الرئاسه
بفتره واحده غير قابله للتجديد زيدان
زينجو العربيه انقره